Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is my Full
House the Dragon episode 10 finale video there's
a whole bunch of Easter eggs and references so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel I will be doing a bunch of bonus
videos during the break between season one and
season two and I will start doing more season two
videos this week so be sure to subscribe to get
everything careful for spoilers for the episode
if you haven't seen it yet but we'll start at
the beginning work our way through shop by shot
talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments starting
with the episode title it was the black queen
a reference to rhaenyra when she crowns herself
Queen with her father viserys's crown just like
they now call The Greens small Council the green
council her small council is called the black
Council as well because now you have the king
and the queen operating at the same time during
the actual Dance of the dragons and even though
you could point to a number of different points
during the season where you could say this is
the start of the actual dance of the Dragons if
you're talking about actual battles the real start
technically happens at Storm's end like the Battle
of Storm's end between amend and luceras R.I.P to
that special little boy have to pay respects he
didn't want to fight and clearly aemond wasn't
actually trying to kill him I'll explain why that
happened why it went down that way when we get to
that part of the episode because it's them paying
off something that viserys was talking to Bernier
about in episode one when she was much younger
about the targaryen's relationship to dragons it's
also a way to show you that this whole episode
is basically about a classic Game of Thrones
theme like the best Game of Thrones episodes like
you're talking about the original seasons of Game
of Thrones some of the best seasons are about
really great meetings and how after everyone
spends all this time having these really great
meetings things just go completely off the rails
like seeing how wrong everything goes in the most
spectacularly WTF kind of way because this whole
episode is them having a giant meeting around
the map table in the map table room it looked
fantastic I love the big glow up literally and
metaphorically that they gave to the map table
during this series and even though it seems like
rhaenyra might avert War like she doesn't want to
rule over the ashes which is also something that
Daenerys said during the Game of Thrones series
things go wrong in the worst possible way because
it wouldn't be otherwise in game of Thrones like
it's not Game of Thrones unless things go terribly
terribly wrong for everyone during the opening
titles there are a few minor changes that reflect
the events of episodes eight and nine at the very
start when they show aegon the conqueror symbol
Matt Smith's name appears first replacing Paddy
considine's name because he's dead he's not on the
show anymore you also notice that Steve Toussaint
is back in the opening credits because Corlys
Velaryon returns in this episode he wasn't in
the last few ones and also because of viserys's
death because they're finally reflecting that his
symbol fills with blood like the ones before like
each time someone dies in this line of succession
as the blood flows from simple to symbol from
father to children like the intro scene has been
a really creative family tree like a 3D model
of their family tree on Ancient Valeria because
they are meant to be the blood of old Valeria
the actual opening scene is of luceris looking
at the unlit map table by himself in the room
in this whole scene with rhaenyra is obviously
meant to foreshadow his death at the end of the
episode like he could become great one day even
though he thinks that he's not going to amount
to anything it's her telling him it's okay to
be afraid like even when I was named air I was
afraid I didn't think that I was ready also the
funny thing during their conversation too is
that he says that she's perfect like he thinks
of her as a perfect person which obviously we
know isn't true because otherwise he wouldn't
have been born a bastard like she breaks rules
left and right she even references that later
like my father loved me very much and tried to
help me along the way and that's been one of the
big contentious things that the greens have come
after her for like her father has been protecting
her this whole time but she keeps messing up left
and right but obviously the whole sad tone of the
music over this scene is just meant to foreshadow
basically the entire episode but mostly the end of
the episode like the whole episode is meant to be
all about loss things that renyra loses first she
loses her father viserys he dies she also learns
in the same moment that she's lost the crown in
the iron throne and then she loses her third child
with daemon the girl that was named vicenya after
aegon the Conqueror sister wife bessenia she also
wielded dark sister daemon's Villa and sword so
there was like a lot of meaning in them naming
her visenya then she loses luceris at the end of
the episode episode her second child with Harmony
strong so the subtitle for this episode should be
how much can rhaenyra lose in her life and still
keep going like how much can be taken away from
rhaenyra so it's a very very sad episode even
though they end the episode with that very drum
beat Drums of War version of The Game of Thrones
theme song they also start the camera on the map
table on the North and Winterfell to foreshadow
her conversation with daemon about aegon the
conqueror's dragon dream about the long night
A Song of Ice and Fire and Winterfell and the
Starks really happy to see that they're bringing
the Starks back into the story Krieg and Stark who
they mentioned later in the episode is who jakaris
is going to treat with eventually at the beginning
of season 2 at some point his father ricken is the
one that swore the oath to rhaenyra when she was
younger during the Game of Thrones series they
named rickon after this rickon and even though
we don't get into a whole bunch of Winterfell
stuff during this episode they just referenced it
several times Cregan Stark went through something
similar is what's happening to rhaenyra right now
with a succession of their family like the Stark
Family itself came into question where an uncle
was trying to see his power for himself and
wasn't handing it to the rightful son so Cregan
is sympathetic to what's happening to rhaenyra
right now the camera also descends from the middle
of the Kingdom around the riverlands the King's
Landing harrenhal because as Daemon says this area
is going to be the most critical part of Westeros
for them to control in the dance of the Dragons we
meet one of the other kingsguard for the first
time this is Laurent Mar brand he's one of the
special ones that's basically been on rhaenyra
duty like alicenthas Kristen Cole on her personal
security detail rhaenyrahas versions of that too
he's mostly a decent person he's honorable loyal
to rhaenyra like he swears fealty to her like the
other kings guard that are on Dragonstone at the
time he doesn't get up to any really shady stuff
or anything like that like he's not like Criston
Cole he's not a terrible person or anything like
that rhaenys then finally arrives on melees and
explains everything that happened her father's
death what they did with aegon II trying to
crown him steal her crown it just the shock of
everything causes her to miscarry like it causes
her to go into labor way earlier than she's
supposed to it turns into one of the most wtf
scenes that we've probably ever seen on any Game
of Thrones series like the original series or this
current series the way the books recorded this
event they talk about they kind of brush over a
little but they take it mostly as an ill portent
of things to come like things were only going to
get worse from here on out and that's kind of the
way the episode treats this scene too like this
is the beginning of the end like the beginning
of things getting really really bad for everyone
daemon is clearly upset at the loss of their child
but the thing about daemon in this episode is
they really try to make it clear in all the scenes
that he's doing everything he can to push rhaenyra
to declare war like immediately after he finds
out what happens he starts theorizing that the
greens actually poisoned his brother like he died
under mysterious circumstances they did something
there might have been a little of that like Otto
Hightower said he had all these contingency plans
to kill off for an era and steal the crown no
matter what like they were always going to try and
put aegon the second on the Iron Throne regardless
of how things went down but even if they were
trying to hasten viserys's death and keep him
bedridden that would have eventually happened no
matter what like his illness was so degenerative
was hurting his body so much much that even if
they have been able to help a little they would
only extended his life by a couple years so even
though during this entire episode it seems like
daemon goes full little finger like chaos is a
ladder let's try to thrive in chaos which reminds
me of that funny conversation today with Tywin
where he tries to give him the same chaos as a
ladder of speech in Taiwan kind of claps back at
him saying that's a stupid idea he would say that
as if you were the first man alive to think it
yes a crisis is an opportunity what other
brilliant insights have you brought me today
despite daemon doing all that he's not totally off
base like he's a little bit correct in thinking
that the greens did something shady and one of
the other big ideas that they try to get across
and all of raniero's scenes during this episode in
particularly in episode 9 as well if it wasn't as
clear in both cases alicentand raniera are trying
to be as cautious and measured about what they
do next as possible avert war as much as possible
because as renura says very plainly in the episode
she doesn't want to rule over the ashes and in
both cases it's all the people around them that
become the biggest problems preventing them from
doing what seems like the right thing to do like
Otto Hightower has all of his plans to kill
rhaenyra and all of her family no matter what
aemond goes full daemon winds up killing lucerys
in on rhaenyra's side daemon basically starts
calling the war banners even though we're near
specifically instructed him not to he even chokes
her out when she seems like she might accept
alicent's terms like how dare you not go to
war then they have a scene with raineys that based
answers a lot of people's biggest question after
the end of episode nine because after episode
nine came out people are like why didn't rainy's
just burn all the greens why didn't she kill aegon
alicent and all of them the queen who didn't say
burn them all her rationale is that there like it
would have been a war over this no matter what but
she didn't think that it was her place to be the
one to actually fire the first shot to be the one
to actually start the war itself and if we're
talking about the actual start I think we can
call the Battle of Storms and like I said aemond
vs luceris and luceris's death the actual start
they have another crazy scene where they intercut
with branera trying to give birth to visenya while
daemon is doing his best to completely ignore
what's going on where all the other people around
the map table like all the other Lords that are
there the other members of the kingsguard the
other regular soldiers they have on Dragonstone
all talking about what they do next you hear
raenyra screams for like the next giant chunk of
the episode and all the other people just keep
looking around like hey daemon do you want to
go maybe check on uh what's going on with the
rhaenyra and the maester and it seems like he's
trying to do everything he can to just complete
completely ignore it he does grieve a little bit
later but it just meant to show you where daemon's
priorities are it's also meant to be a parallel
for rhaenys taking Corlys Velaryonto task when
she's like you left me you were a terrible husband
why did you just take off this is kind of like
daemon's version of the same thing jacarison
luceris's fight practice on the beach is also
meant to foreshadow the end of the episode too
where lucerys very clearly does not like fighting
like he is the opposite of aemond doesn't want
to have anything to do with this the King's Guard
who's helping them there is a new character we
haven't seen before named Stefan darkling but he's
one of the two kingsguard that daemon forces to
bend the knee the reason why rhaenyra then reminds
jakaris that he's Heir is because she's in so
much pain during this birth and because the life
expectancy of people during this era like even
this meant to be a parallel for the Medieval ages
in real life life expectancy was extremely low for
women in this case so she's actually doing a very
good job as a ruler trying to establish a clear
line of authority in case something happens to her
or she becomes bedridden and can't make decisions
look they do want to show you during this episode
that despite the end of the episode she is making
very calm very measured decisions she would be
potentially a very good Queen you also notice that
the boys don't call daemon father they call him
daemon just to remind you that they still think
of Harwin strong as their real father because he
is daemon probably cared for them but I think in
the same way that he cared for laena Velaryon like
he didn't actually love her he doesn't actually
genuinely love them he just cares for them because
he has to when daemon mentions house darklyn
house Massey and Bar Emmon house darklyn is where
Steffon Darklin comes from kingsguard now one
of rhaenyra's kingsguard they control Duskendale
which lies here close to Dragonstone on the coast
house Massey and House Bar Emmon also control
different points on this edge of the bay all the
houses that they reference are houses around the
bay here so it's them basically gaining control
of the entire narrow sea in the entire area around
the Blackwater Bay so they cut off all support for
the greens from the East for the most part that's
why daemon keeps saying that them controlling the
riverlands in harrenhal in the middle here is so
critical because it's them basically boxing in the
greens on both sides most of the trouble that they
reference that they're going to get are coming
from the westerlands because they're controlled
by House Lannister which are firmly Team Green in
any of the other houses loyal to them like they
say west of the golden tooth which is also home
to a place that's controlled by House Lannister
in the gold mines most of their supporters
that were Nero references like those houses
are actually towards the north just because of
their common ancestry and like I said in the
case of the Starks for instance they are going
through a similar experience to what's happening
to rhaenyra right now with someone trying to take
her throne from her and even though daemon tries
to jump the gun and do what raniera told him not
to do send the Ravens out already preemptively and
call the Banners To War like find out who their
supporters actually are he tries to fly caraxes
to the tullys to secure them because they're so
critical technically he's not wrong and wanting
to do that because by the time luceris makes
it to Storm's End aemond has already made it
there and the baratheons were actually really
critical for them to have support like times
of wasting grab as many supporters in the great
houses as you can you also notice when daemon
is making Steffon Darklyn and Laurent Marbrand
swear fealty the structure behind them seems
like an old house that hasn't been used in a long
time like maybe someone used it before the time
of aegon's conquest it's just a way to remind
you that Dragonstone is a very big island and
we've only seen parts of it so far and a lot
of people are confused about how caraxis seems
to have this weird telepathic link with daemon
like does he control the dragon telepathically
that's not exactly what's happening usually the
strength of people's bonds with their dragons
is dependent upon the strength of their own well
daemon's very strong-willed person so that's not
a big issue for him but they don't actually have
a real telepathic link with the dragons like he
can't give the dragon commands telepathically
when they're close enough the dragons can pick
up on their emotions and just respond to that
they can also see visual cues too like if the
person seems like they're pulling out their sword
and getting really pissed off the dragons pick up
on that like oh time to burn something get ready
for them to say dracaris there are a lot of scenes
like this during the Game of Thrones series with
Daenerys and her dragons like if the dragons are
close enough they kind of pick up on her emotions
if something is wrong with her they get really
pissed off but it's not like Daenerys was calling
drogue onto her like drogon come to me save me it
was more like her freaking out and drogon sensing
that like oh my mother is freaking out I need to
go help her this also sets up what happens with
aemond and luceros later in the episode where
vhagar disobeys him and attacks air acts against
his direct wishes like even when he's yelling at
vhagar who doesn't listen to him it's a good
example of how the bond actually works between
dragons and writers like their bond doesn't give
them absolute control over the dragons the dragons
still have this fight or flight Instinct that's
way more powerful this Primal Instinct that kicks
in when they're in trouble in for example vhagar
was responding to arrax blasting her with fire so
she's like how dare somebody tried to come kill me
I'm gonna go take care of that this sort of kicks
her into Primal fighter flight mode and anything
else just becomes background noise to her like
aemond screaming at her just background noise
at that point they use it to pay off viserys's
conversation with rhaenyra when she was younger
in front of blurring the black dreads skull saying
that the targaryens controlling dragons isn't
a real thing like that's is a myth their power
we should have never trifled with and this is a
good example like aemond doesn't actually control
vhagar more like giving polite suggestions to
vhagar that she can choose not to listen to if she
doesn't feel like it maybe you don't eat my nephew
here you know what I'm not gonna do that I'm gonna
eat this dragon and your nephew it's sort of like
real life where you hear about people who keep
giant exotic animals like giant tigers or lions as
pets and they eventually get mauled by those pets
even if they seem docile up to that point during
the scene of daemon telling the kingsguard to
bend the knee they also intercut with rhaenyra's
birth thing they also flash the scenes of syrax
reacting to rhaenyra's birth as well like I said
low level Bond syrax is picking up on rhaenyra's
pain which is why syrax starts crying out when he
tells them if they turn on them later they betray
them they'll die screaming that's foreshadowing
for future Seasons not specifically for these
two kingsguard but just metaphorically going
into the future because this is Game of Thrones
betrayal is par for the course and when rhaenyraa
actually loses her child visenya it's meant to be
a parallel for what happened to her mother
AMA dying in childbirth trying to give birth
to their last son she's even wearing the exact
same clothing that her mother was wearing you
also noticed during the barrel ceremony the silent
sisters are standing behind them because Ranier
is doing it all herself normally they wouldn't
do that like renira is grieving by doing this
herself during the actual burial ceremony when
they burned the body as is the Targaryen custom
I believe they also play the same sad music track
that they've used in previous episodes for similar
scenes like this I want to say they use the same
music track during her mother's funeral scene
then Eric who had escaped from King's Landing
earlier stole her father viserys's Crown so
that she could crown herself Queen in the oath
that he's reciting is the traditional oath that
all kingsguard takes just in general when they
become one or when a newer king or queen comes
along succeeding the last one daemon also plays
in the crowd on her head as a parallel for him
putting the crown on his brother's head previously
and while they're crowning her they play the same
theme music from episode 1 at the end where
her father had been forcing everyone to bend
need to her as a child then next to war like time
for our real Great War planning meeting they start
checking supplies and weapons we see them dress
up the map table as aegon the Conqueror would have
when he was planning the conquest of the Seven
Kingdoms it's meant to be a parallel for that
you also have to admire how they've given this
literal and metaphorical glow up to the map table
like it's the same one from the Game of Thrones
series but they've enhanced it in little ways just
to make it way cooler looking like they use the
candlelight to light it up and make it function
like an actual map daemon then introduces her to
the room for the first time using her full title
as Queen of the Seven Kingdoms when he says first
of her name that's because when you ascend the
Iron Throne you become king or queen you actually
get the number designation so for instance she and
daemon have a child named aegon III alicent's
son is named aegon II even Jon Snow would have
been named aegon VI Patty sat on the Iron Throne
otherwise Jon Snow would have just been called
to regular old aegon if he'd grown up in King's
Landing and not taken the Iron Throne when he says
Queen of the Andals the royner and the first men
those are the three major ethnic groups in West
Rose the first men were literally the first
actual humans to occupy Westeros they came over
on the land bridge about 12 000 years ago about
two thousand years before the first long night
the Andals invaded Westeros about four thousand
years ago they originally came from this northern
part of essos up here they brought the faith of
the seven so that's why there's a high septon
in present day because of the andal influence the
people closer to the Andals in their genetic lines
exist around the middle of Westeros the people
up in the north like the Starks Winterfell the
errands mostly descend from the first men and
then the roiner are literally nymeria and her
ten thousand ships who invaded Dorne about 700
years ago so when we talk about nymeria in the 10
000 ships she's a royner princess who first fought
and lost a war against the Valyrian Freehold who
were expanding into their territory she took the
survivors and sailed them to what became Dorne
that's part of the reason why the martells
and Dorne have always hated the targaryens
because the valyrians were the whole reason
why they had to leave essos all the people in
the room here are amongst the houses that they
mentioned are supporting them at the start here
daemon also says that he sent word to his men in
the city watch that are still loyal to him but
remember he created the gold cloaks even though
it's been several years some of his men still sit
on the gold cloaks when maester Girardi says that
house celtagar and house Staunton already sworn
to them they're standing in the room here like
this is bartimos celtegar they're actually the
third house in the realm who comes from ancient
Valeria so later in the episode where they say
a mysterious ship flying a green Banner with a
three-headed dragon on it has appeared that's
a reference to the three Bloodlines that come
from ancient Valeria that are in Westeros House
Targaryen House of valerion and house celtagar
but the celtaguards themselves are not Dragon
Riders neither are most of the valerians some of
them are but not all them and like I said all the
houses they mentioned that support them initially
like right at the start here control the northern
part of the Blackwater Bay in the southern
part as well as Corlys Velaryonin driftmark
we find out also Now controls the stepstones which
basically gives them control of the entire narrow
sea Massey bar Amman darklin are the other Lords
who form her black Council like her version of
the small Council basically everybody around the
bay here becomes part of her small Council Corlys
Velaryonwinds up becoming her hand of the queen
and Masseria Becomes Her Mistress of Whispers
rhaenyra reminds us that her mother was from house
Aaron so they'll likely support them her mother
was of Targaryen blood she and viserys were first
cousins her mother was jahiris's youngest daughter
then really funny Easter egg here that you guys
probably noticed with their reactions when they
say they're going to send for help from house
Tully they talk about the lord of the house his
name is Grover Tully as in Grover from Sesame
Street his son's name is Kermit Telly in the
sun's son like the grandson is also named Kermit
so it just seems like George R Martin is a big
fan of Jim Henson as he should be but now we have
Sesame Street and Muppets in Game of Thrones they
mentioned house Baratheon and Storm's end just
said at the end of the episode with luceris and
amid in what's happened during the last time junk
the last six years is that Borman Baratheon the
one who actually supported her in benthani has
died and his son has become Lord of Storm's end
the reason why she's so sure that they'll support
them is because of the their common bloodline now
she references rhaenys but they actually go way
back with the baratheons all the way to aegon the
Conqueror luceris is basically like the cousin
of Boris Baratheon because rainey's mother was
a Baratheon she was the sister of borros's father
but if you remember house Baratheon actually was
created from a bastard from House Targaryen so
Orman Baratheon first of his name was actually
the bastard half brother of aegon the Conqueror
they were great friends growing up and after he
defeated argelak durandan in the stormlands during
the war of Conquest aegon basically gave him the
stormlands and that created house Baratheon Robert
Baratheon during the main Game of Thrones series
is also part Targaryen through his grandmother's
side so he was cousins with Daenerys and Jon
Snow even though he didn't know that then when
bartimo saltagar mentions all their dragons and
daemon starts talking about numbers like here's
how many we control versus The Greens currently
their side has access to 13 with potentially more
in the future to the greens four with potentially
the greens getting more in the future as well too
remember everyone inside the actual nuclear royal
families are Dragon Riders but but some of the
youngest ones who were just born recently are
too young to actually ride dragons which is why
the numbers aren't higher but the big idea is
that Ranier has access to more than three times
as many dragons as the greens do which gives them
more power theoretically they have a daemon and
rhaenyra's dragons craxies and syrax jakaris and
lucerus's Dragons of Vermax and aerax baby Joffrey
has a dragon called taraxis which daemon mentions
bala's dragon is named Moon Dancer Reyna doesn't
have one yet but she'll get one eventually rhaenys
has melees and his demon says they have access to
several more like sea smoke laners Dragon still
resides on driftmark but is currently riderless
Silverwing and vermithor were alisan and joharis's
former dragons who've gone rightless since they
died vermouthor is also the largest oldest dragon
in the Kingdom next to vagar which is why he's
such a huge asset metaphorically and literally
in all three wild dragons Roost on Dragonstone
currently but they're only able to claim one
of them eventually its cannibal Gray Ghost and
sheep stealer so now there's this Mad Dash to
find anybody bastards and all who have a little
bit of Targaryen blood just enough to bond with
Dragons because they have more dragons and they
have actual Riders right at the moment so when we
say they're going to introduce more Dragon seeds
in season two it's just people that are capable
of riding dragons currently the greens only have
access to Amos Dragon Veigar aegon the second's
dragon Sunfire and Helena's Dragon dream fire
but remember Helena has two children at least
right here who are old enough will be able to ride
dragons soon in a third potentially daemon's main
plan initially at least is to invade harrenhal and
use it as their main base of operations because
it's so centralized They Don't Really address
that after this in the episode so I'm assuming
that'll be one of the earliest WTF battles they
have at the beginning of season two because you
also remember the curse of harrenhal strange
things befall the people who hold harrenhal also
it's a parallel for aegon in the conquest burning
harrenhal so when daemon summons vermithor and he
breathes all this far like a very extended fire
breathing sequence it's like them foreshadowing
him taking vermithor to burn harrenhal as they
take it and because Lair is strong Lord weirdo
foot ho holds the castle it's not like they have
any moral quandary with them sieging the castle
the whole scene on the bridge with Otto Hightower
is meant to be a parallel for their standoff in
episode 2. rhaenyra appearing the same way she
did before averting disaster like it seemed like
daemon probably would have tried to kill Otto if
rhaenyra hadn't showed up just like he would have
done back during episode two you notice when Otto
is reading alicent's terms to her alicent's words
describe jacaerys and luceris as their true
born Sons meaning if she accepts her terms
all the greens will stop it with all the strong
boy stuff they'll be allowed to keep Dragonstone
driftmark in their family lines but they have to
give up all claims to the iron throne and even
though it seems like she might accept it and they
might avert War you remember Otto Hightower had
no plans to let things go through this way he was
going to kill rhaenyra and her family any chance
he got no matter what is another example of how
alicentrhaenyra try to solve things sensibly but
everybody around them like daemon on radera's side
and Otto Hightower on alicent's side trying to do
everything they can to burn the realm to the
ground when daemon says he'd rather feed their
sons to to a dragon that foreshadows lucerius's
death at the end of the episode because that
pretty much what happens to luceris he's basically
eaten by vhagar because when the pieces of air X
are falling into the sea you don't see any of
luceris's bits vhagar is so big though it'd be
like being eaten by a house Otto Hightower also
mentions Storm's end they've sent Ravens already
they've sent aemond just foreshadowing the end
of the episode when they mention the Tulles 2
the tullys are a bit like what's going on in
Storm's end like it's a situation where you
have half the family that support the greens and
the other half that supports for an era so it's
a big question as to which side that they'll go
with but obviously they're leaving that for season
two then he gives her the page of the history
book that raniera tore out the day that she and
alicenthad been reading in the godswood when
they were younger so despite all the acrimony
between them everything that happened across
the years it's meant to be a symbol of their
relationship alicenthad kept it this whole time
like there'd always been a chance that they'd
eventually make up which they kind of did at the
end of episode 8 but then obviously things go
completely off the rails the page is what makes
rhaenyra actually consider accepting alicent's
terms even though daemon chokes are out for it the
actual page was all about Princess nymeria the 10
000 ships in her invasion of Dorne it was meant
to be a parallel for rhaenyra like a powerful
woman Queen because nymeria wound up becoming the
first queen of Dorne arya's direwolf is also named
after her so she's like the most famous woman in
the history of Westeros next to Daenerys although
Daenerys is more Infamous than famous for obvious
reasons but you get the parallel here like they're
trying to make you wonder based on what happens
in this episode and what will eventually happen
to the dance of the dragons with the scorched
Earth policy well what happens with renura be
more like what happened with Daenerys or will it
be more like princess nymeria conquering Dorne
also zoom and enhance on the part of the actual
text of this page about nymeria talks about her
Fleet dispersing during the first storm sweeping
the coast you could call that foreshadowing for
the Storm at Storm's end that luceris dies in
at the end of the episode with aemondn vhagar
and when she says she'll give them her answer
tomorrow had luceris not been killed by aemond
they want you to think that she probably would
have accepted the terms like it's luceris's death
that catalyzes her to call for a full-blown war
in the actual start of the dance of the Dragons
which is why the war drums music starts beating
at the end of this like the war drums version
of The Game of Thrones theme song and I'm sure
aemond is going to regret his actions along with
all the other terrible stuff most people will
do on both sides of the rest of the conflict in
future Seasons like it's full-on scorched Earth
the phrase that she mentioned to Daemon earlier
is very important I don't want to rule over the
ashes and when dragons go to war everything gets
burned Daemon talking about dragons killing other
dragons dragon slaying is more foreshadowing for
the end of the episode you can also say it's
foreshadowing for the rest of the dance of the
Dragons just in general too because there's going
to be so many dragon battles and when she talks to
him about aegon's prophecy you also notice that
she's standing near the north of the table right
near the actual wall the Frozen North the lands of
always winter and we find out that viserys never
told Daemon about aegon's prophecy of A Song of
Ice and Fire the long night the white walkers so
even though Daemon understands what dragon dreams
are he knows that they exist it sounds like he's
just trying to ignore everything she says as
nonsense because he wants War so so badly I'm
really interested to see with his character in
future Seasons if they pay this moment off in
some interesting way with Daemon getting his
comeuppance so to speak by learning about the
white walkers the hard way like either gets turned
into a white walker or a white or something like
that something similar because the books never
fully explain what happened to Daemon at the end
of the dance of the Dragons they just say that he
disappeared quote unquote after his final fight
so it just leaves a lot of room for the show to
pay off his ending in some really creative epic
way you can let me know in the comments like
what do you think will eventually happen to
Daemon at the end like will he get turned into a
white or a white walker or something like that we
finally get to see Corlys Velaryon come back and
rainy has it out with him basically kicking him
to tasks for being a terrible husband you kind of
expect a version of this with rhaenyra and daemon
at some point too like boroniro is actually like
you're a terrible partner for me he wants to pack
it all up go back to driftmark and just secure
his house like we need to take care of our own
to ensure the survival of our house the reason why
they can't do that is because he wants lucerys to
take driftmark eventually and the greens have to
kill all of rhaenyra's family at least initially
he declares for rheanyra and they get rhaenys in
melees as well because obviously she comes with
her husband but it's very clear that Corlys does
not like rhaenyra so keep an eye on him long term
also a big surprise turns out he didn't know
what happened to his brother during episode 8
while he was recovering this also the reason why
Daemon makes himself scarce when corlys comes to
Dragonstone like where's Daemon oh you know he
had stuff to do he's busy somewhere else just
because probably wasn't a good idea for him to
be standing there when corlys walked in if they
wanted his support when bartimos celtegar suggests
laying siege to the red keep that's meant to be a
parallel for Daenerys burning King's Landing seige of
King's Landing but it takes a long time for
that to actually happen so they'll be like the end
of season two maybe the end of season three they
send all the kids off in different directions to
treat with the great houses to see whose support
they can get and her telling them not to fight is
just to set up the aemond versus lucerys' fight
where he refuses to fight tries to fly away and
despite their best efforts even aiming to lose
saris's efforts the dragons go at it these three
dragons that are flying off are arrax and Vermax
the boys dragons and rainey's on meleys who said
she was going to go Patrol the gullet Daemon goes
to the dragon caves on Dragonstone singing a
Valyrian song summoning vermithor like I said
biggest oldest Dragon next to vhagar and the
fact that he blows so much fire here probably
just foreshadowing their Siege of harrenthal using
him just like aegon the conqueror use blurring the
black dread to burn harrenhal great way to stick
it to Lara strong too even though they don't
know about all the weird feet stuff when lucerus
arrives at storm's end we get the best look at the
exterior of the castle they've ever given us love
the foreshadowing of vhagar in the background just
to give you a sense and scale of the dread like
the whole part of the episode kind of turns into
more of a horror story than a thriller the weather
in the stormlands is also usually like this that's
why they call it the stormlands we meet borros
baratheon for the first time then they had this
funny moment real briefly where he gives him the
message and they imply that borros can't read like
he gets really upset when he looks at the note
someone bring the maester because the maester
has to read it and explain it to him even though
it seems weird that someone so Highborn as him
can't read that's not unusual for medieval times
in books for instance were extremely expensive and
valuable which is why it was such a big deal that
renero ripped the page out of that one book that
alicentkept you have to imagine that most of the
realm is actually illiterate can you read everyone
can you read even though he seems
really prickly his major objection
to their message is mostly that they don't
offer him anything like a marriage to his
daughters or something else like he just
wants some form of payment from rhaenyra
or some tribute which the greens did offer even
though he doesn't say they imply that because
aymond is standing next to one of his daughters
here they pledged aemond's hand in marriage to
one of his daughters aemond goes full-on Daemon
chaos is a ladder and won't let him leave without
pushing for a fight wanting a chance at revenge
an eye for an eye calling him a strong boy telling
him to take his eye out just like they did back
in the past revealing the sapphire eye that now
sits in the place of the one that he lost this is
also right out of the books like he had a sapphire
fake eye and like I said earlier I don't think
aemond wanted to kill him he just wants to see
him experience some pain and toy with him in a
really sadistic kind of way clearly things got
out of hand that's why I said earlier they pay
off this earlier comment about them not really
being able to control dragons because even though
luceris tries to fly away like he just tries to
get away as fast as possible it seems like when
arrax attacked Vega that was him going rogue it
wasn't luceras telling him to attack vhagar then
it triggers vhagar's flight or flight response
who goes after arrax and lucera's dying as just
collateral damage of that it's just an unfortunate
side effect but now we get to see how Daemon
in rhaenyra are going to respond to that like
they said they're going to give the greens their
response on the Maro their response is probably
going to be something really crazy Daemon is
probably going to go off the chain with his
revenge they're all chasing his death scene was
also great too so rip press F to pay respects
too bad we'll have to wait till the beginning
of season 2 to actually see them pay off their
revenge but overall it was a great episode great
finale I felt like they did a good job of wrapping
things up and pushing into season two it felt a
lot like the older Sseasons the original seasons
of Game of Thrones if you spotted any other big
easter eggs or references in the episode that it
didn't talk about in the video or big questions
just write them below in the comments and I'll
do a big top 10 WTF predictions video for season
two next you can click here for that I'll update
the link as soon as I post that and click here
for all my other house the dragon videos thank
you so much for watching everyone stay it
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!